[Music]
[Applause]
you can see Tony Dungy NBC football
night in America and of course the
former Colts Buccaneers head coach and a
Hall of Famer who joins us on the
program Tony great to see you what was
your reaction when Jeff's uh Saturday
got the job
probably like everybody else in the in
the country I was like what wow and my
wife said the same thing
um it's just kind of amazing I was
talking to Jeff probably four days ago
talking about uh doing a speaking
engagement down in his home area in
Georgia and could we get it together and
uh next thing I know he's the head coach
of the Colts so strange things strange
times but I think he'll do well any
involvement in that decision by Jim
irsay
no not at all um I Heard it the same
time everybody else in the country heard
it yeah I'm surprised I was surprised
that he let Frank Wright go at this
point in time
um just that that one caught me by
surprise but uh moving forward Jim I
know he wanted somebody who knew the lay
of the land somebody who was passionate
about the the Colts you're kind of
limited in your options at this point in
time so I know to a lot of people Jeff
doesn't make sense but but to me I could
see I could see this happening yeah but
explain what role he's going to have as
a former head coach he's never done it
what role is he going to play this
Sunday against the Raiders
he's going to be the leader and he's
going to Rally people together and I
don't know this for a fact but I'm
thinking that part of Jim Murphy's
thought process is that we've got one of
the highest paid offensive lines in
football our offensive line is was going
to be the strength of our team and it's
not
so now I can have a chance to bring
someone in who can get that part of
things going and I think Jeff will do
that
is this long-term plan for Jim or say I
don't think it is I think this was a
eight games let's see if we can make
something happen here and then you know
we'll we'll go from there hey we turn it
around and win six out of eight and you
know make the playoffs maybe it is but
at this point what can we do to salvage
this season and
um you know it's funny DPI was when when
I talked to owners and they're making a
decision usually it's in the off season
but you talk what are you looking for
well I didn't ask Jim Mercy I didn't
have that conversation but I promise you
what he was looking for was somebody who
could lead
and energize people and who could get
the offensive line fixed that's what he
was looking for in this little window so
and from that standpoint it makes sense
I remember when Mike Ditka got hired by
the Bears
and I Mike Ditka was a special teams
coach with the Cowboys he was a
hot-headed guy I remember saying this
has no chance of working but George
Halas what he was looking for was
somebody who was passionate about the
Bears who knew the Bears operation and
the bears were the most important thing
to him that's what he was looking for
that's what he found and for them it
worked it might not have worked for Mike
Ditka anywhere else in the National
Football League but there at that point
it worked you were a coordinator
defensive coordinator then of course the
head coach give me the difference
between somebody who's a coordinator and
a head coach day to day or certainly on
game day
the head coach you are managing the game
you're making things work and some guys
now I never did it this way some guys
stay in that offensive or defensive
coordinator role they want to be the
play caller they're running still one
side of the ball for me I thought I need
to run this team make sure everybody's
in position to do what they do best to
help the coordinators and the assistant
coaches do their jobs and just put
everybody in position and I think that's
the way Jeff's going to handle it and I
think he'll do well at that
did you call plays when you were head
coach
I did not and uh it kind of
went back to my playing days I played
for Chuck Knoll and he stayed right in
the middle looked at both sides kind of
controlled everything had a little bit
something to say but he let us
coordinators run it I played for Bill
Walsh one year and Bill Walsh was the
offensive coordinator and Brilliant at
it and called the offensive but for me I
felt like a stepchild on the defensive
side of the ball okay that's his thing
the offense is where he's at he's never
in our meetings he doesn't know what's
going on over here he trusts you know
his defensive coordinator but his thing
is offense so I well if I ever want to
be a head coach I didn't want my guys to
feel that way that I'm in the middle I'm
there with both sides anybody can come
and ask me a question and I'm going to
know the answer get them pointed in the
right direction so I always stayed right
in the middle and I let the coordinators
do it if Jeff Saturday called you
what would you say
I would say follow your gut follow your
convictions lead this team very well uh
support those those coaches first thing
he's got to do is figure out who's going
to call the plays on offense exactly
just fired their offensive coordinator
offensive coordinator is not there the
the guy who called the plays is not
there nobody on the staff has called
plays in an NFL game so that's the first
thing you've got to come up with and
then you've got to support that and say
who we're going to be and and what are
we going to be and how are we going to
do this and um he'll he'll do well but
it's a very very tough situation I I
wouldn't wish this situation on anybody
talking to Tony Dungy the Hall of Famer
joining us on the program we were also
talking about what's going on with
Buffalo with Josh Allen with that arm or
the ulnar nerve which if you're a
pitcher that's a big deal I I'm
wondering Buffalo doesn't have that
cushion in the division where hey we can
sit him down for a little while and
maybe rest that but uh what do you think
the options are here with Josh Allen and
I don't know how you can protect a guy
who plays like that oh it would be very
concerning to me because they are built
around him if you're Tennessee Titans
you can put Malik Willison throw eight
passes and you still have a chance to
win the game Buffalo cannot do that jazz
Allen has to be on fire for them to win
so uh I I don't know how you you go
about it you you can't protect them
because he he plays too aggressively
um and and they've got to have him
throwing well to win so this really kind
of changes the landscape of the AFC East
to me
how would you devise a defense to try to
contain Lamar Jackson
well there's been different ways that
people have tried to do it it's so hard
to play zone coverage that's what I
would want to do is play zone so I've
got all my seven defenders in the back
with their eyes on him and they can see
him and rally to him when he runs but
the these rpos that people are running
they fake it in there they get their
linebackers to play run and then there's
holes in the zones to throw those quick
passes and everybody is taking advantage
of that so now you have to almost play
man-to-man and that's tough I think I
would probably call Bob Sanders and say
can you play can you give me one game
and just buy this guy you would be my
middle linebacker and all you're gonna
do is spy Lamar I don't know and I've
said this before I don't know if there's
a quarterback who has more
responsibility than Lamar Jackson does
given that he doesn't have running backs
he doesn't have wide receivers he
doesn't have Mark Andrews there you're
you're basically saying Lamar you cannot
have an off day if we're going to win
I I saw them play down here in Tampa I
went to the game and it was amazing
because you're right he dictated
everything on offense the Tampa defense
had to react to him the whole way and
then last night uh that that was a
pretty good defense he was playing
against in New Orleans and he just he
was the dominant player on the field and
he has to do it he has to be dominant
for them week in and week out and and
he's doing it we talk about NBA teams
tanking how often does tanking happen in
the NFL
I was never around a team that had the
chance to do it or did it
um
the the NFL draft isn't like the NBA
draft where you get this guy and you're
guaranteed success you know we've seen
Tim Couch and you know number one draft
choice quarterbacks that haven't you
know done it for you
um there was the tanking for Tua and
maybe Justin Herbert maybe that is not a
bad alternative so I just don't it
hasn't come up
I I think you get more of hey it doesn't
matter how many we win we're not going
to be a playoff team so let's build for
the future let's find out what these
young guys can do uh my first year in
Tampa we said that Trent delpher was
going to be the quarterback no matter
what we've got to find out he was the
sixth pick in the draft can he do it so
we could go on 16 but he's going to play
until we find out he either can or can't
now that's not the same as tanking we
didn't say hey we're going to lose every
game but we had objectives looking at
the future and I think that's more of
what happens in the NFL than just say oh
Bo Jackson's out there let's lose every
game so we can get him
could you tank could you as a head coach
if if you knew that that was the game
plan
I I couldn't actually tank because it's
too difficult you put so much energy and
effort guys go out there and get hurt I
I can't go out there and say we're not
going to try to win this game now I
could say hey we're going to play these
players we're going to play these young
guys we're going to do this and You're
Gonna Give It All We Got and if we don't
win that's okay but I'm not ever going
to go in and say you know what we're
going to play but we're going to lose
this game if Jim or say had called you
and asked you to be the coach the second
half of the season for the Colts you
would have said what
I would have said Jim I can give you
some recommendation but uh there's no
way I can do this especially if you're
going to tell me I can't play the two
quarterbacks that might give us a chance
to win explain that to me you've got
these two that's why it feels like this
they're tanking here Tony because you're
not playing the better quarter Sim
Ellinger looked lost out there he looked
like he hadn't played and you got Nick
Foles and Matt Ryan who aren't going to
play for you explain that to me yeah
Matt Ryan I guess it's the fact that
it's contracts and we play so much then
you pay this money next year if he gets
hurt as much as guaranteed and so you
think okay we're not going to make the
playoffs so we're not going to win a
Super Bowl so so we're not going to do
that but Nick Foles I can't understand I
love Nick Foles and I think in this
situation a guy who can get rid of the
ball quick who knows the the NFL
landscape who has done this in the past
and led teams on second half marches I
I'm not sure why he's not playing it's
it's incredible it really is where
you're going all right are you trying to
win because you you don't want to win
because you want to get a high draft
pick so you can find your quarterback
right well yeah I I just don't know if
that's okay I mean just looking at the
way things have happened
um
go back we're watching Patrick Mahomes
and we're saying he's generational he
was the third quarterback in that that
draft that you know that you didn't have
to get the first pick to take him and if
you had the top pick and you know you
maybe didn't use it why is there you
picked the guy everybody thought you
should pick and it didn't turn out that
way well you had you know the Colts had
Andrew Luck then Jacoby Brissette and
Brian Hoyer Philip Rivers who was 39
Carson Wentz 37 year old Matt Ryan and
Sam Ellinger I mean they have a roster
that I thought was Super Bowl quality it
was could you get something out of your
quarterback and they got nothing out of
those quarterbacks
yeah well I I think Jeff's plan is going
to be hey we've got a dynamic running
back we've got to help our defense out
we've got to run Jonathan Taylor we've
got to be able to throw play action
passes and we've got to execute at the
quarterback position can Sam do that uh
let's see
um and then if he can't
guys I think you have to try to think
Nick Foles can do that we've seen him do
that yeah I just wonder if they're gonna
let him you know get an opportunity
there
I don't know that that baffled me that
statement that Sam Ellinger is going to
be our quarterback the rest of the
season yeah I just said how can you say
that when you've never seen him play in
an NFL game what if he goes in and he he
does look lost do you just say he's
going to be the quarterback the rest of
the season when you've got two really
good two quarterbacks who've been in
Super Bowls I know how do you say that
Sam Ellinger is going to be the
quarterback the rest of the season that
one the more we're talking the more I'm
shocked at jimmersei would not reach out
to you to ask you your opinion as a you
know consult him on what what to do in
that situation I really am surprised wow
I think he had his mind made up what
what he was going to do I I well would
you talk to him out of that
as a fan and a former Colt I would have
said hey Jim
you've got as many wins as the Rams the
Super Bowl defending champs have that no
there's no super teams out there get
this going stay with Frank let's see if
we can win a few games here get back in
the race if you make the play you
already beat the Kansas City Chiefs
everybody's saying they're going to the
Super Bowl
you already beat them so if you get in
who knows what's going to happen so stay
with the best course of attack to get
you in these playoffs always great to
talk to you my best uh to the gang there
on uh Sunday Night Football thanks all
righty
see you DP That's Tony Dungy Hall of
Famer